welcome to this video a new part of the
middlegame strategy series yeah one aim
of the series is to show pawn structures
of course ideas related to pawn
structures and yeah what kind of pawn
structure some and venegas what
structures are to be avoided let's look
at a sample game and this is from 1962
played by Tigran Petrosian the later
world champion he became world champion
one year later
winning against poor Vinick here playing
white against black player Samuel
chiba-chiba
he's from Argentina this was played in
the Stockholm into zone as mentioned
1962 let's see what happened in this
game Petrosian played D for C form as he
usually did it closed openings most of
the time and we got a king's indian and
Petrosian was well known for having in
fantastic score against the Kings Indian
he really enjoyed playing against the
opening is very much suited his style we
should be too was played castles and
Bishop g5 yeah we don't see the
Petrosian system that could have been
expected but Petrosian also played other
lines against the Kings Indian here it
is the Arabic named after Euro yuri
arabic a line that I also sometimes play
and did you do to him
yeah one reason why I play the line is
the kind of structure that rises here in
this game back in 1962
this line was really a quite new people
did not really really know how to
respond optimally nowadays it is pretty
much pretty much known
that the most promising moves for black
rc5 sorry c-51 night a 6 C 5 is probably
the most most solid choice in fact it is
[ __ ] a shop later but still it's
theoretically speaking probably the
sound smooth after d5 black plays plays
age 6 and so on
Knight a 6 is aiming to structures
comparable to the game but under a
little bit more favorable circumstances
black is actually preparing the movie 5
and once wide to make some sort of
commitment before he plays he five in
the game black played age six and d5
this is also a playable line even
nowadays it is seen sometimes but it is
not believed to be the most precise
after d5 white of course closes the
position black has some some
disadvantages over night a 6-1 is that
the most h6 is weakening the King side a
bit this does look does does not look
very relevant but it will be very very
very very short autumn black now played
the move c6
that's not a bad idea in general trying
to get counter play along the seafoam
however after age 4 like II took the now
played the move Knight bd7 in exactly
this position I think black needed to
consider how to react to the move Age 4
what is the idea of age 4 in fact in the
game we will see what the idea is
white wants to push age 5 and the idea
is not that white is initiating a King
side attack but we look at what happened
in age 5 what white is doing is he
threatens now to take on g6 and take on
age 6 simply winning upon
to be honest sometimes this kind of poor
grep is not that advisable there are
positions like that where this pawn grep
is rather risky especially if white has
played the move f3 already the dark
squares would be very very weak after
that I can give you one example which
does not make particularly huge sense in
a way the concrete moves I mean let's
say black plays this for example yeah
and white responds like here that black
plays mmm let's say a five yeah I just
want to show you the general idea if
white then decides to grab on h6 the
dark square cm I normally week and this
might cost white on the King for example
in this concrete position even Knight h5
as a possible move what must be a
careful with that what black must do
after age form he must do one or two
things he must stop the pawn this is one
possibility however this is sometimes
that it this is something that black
needs to consider carefully at with h5
played the move f5 gets more difficult
to play because your King side is
weakened the other thing is what black
can do is try to play in a way that
after h5 you don't play g5 which gives
the game structure the black player ever
here was pretty much oblivious of all of
that and after h5 he played g5 yeah what
is the problem with this we now get the
following construction f3m a6 on all the
g4 it's all about this pawn structure
the big King's Indian King side clamp
this arises from various opening lines
in the King's Indian it can come from
the our back here it's probably most
typical it can come from Age 3 lines a
3G phone lines or sometimes from the
same
typically blinds where white is not
committing his king early to an early
King side castle but where he pushes
pawns on the Kings side as a sort of a
prophylactic measure what white really
aims for is exactly this structure
Black's problem is mostly that his
bishop on g7 is a dead piece it's only
looking at dark square pawns
it's simply incarcerated on the other
hand White's bishops I excellent he's
got III and II too and they're both
fulfil a useful role on the Queen side
another very different a very M and
important and and sometimes not so
obvious aspect is that both sides have
weak squares on f4 and f5 those two
squares
the big difference however is that white
can actually occupy the square with a
knight from e2 to g3 to f5 note that
white does not want to put a knight
there to let it have exchanged against
the bishop this does not help very much
you want to put a piece there when it is
not possible then black takes it really
as an outpost if we now look at the f4
square this is a different thing
there is no knight coming to the square
simply because the squares ecigs and g6
are safely guarded by white pawns
note that this pawn structure is hugely
different if the pawn is not on h5 but
instead on h3 if white pawn would be
here on h3 then night let's say f8 g 6
to f4 would be possible it's exactly the
structure that is the problem from like
his lacking space and a useful plan
the only constructive thing really that
black can try to do here
is to get the dark squared bishop
exchanges somehow to exchange it to
somehow it's not difficult it's not easy
though it takes lots of time and it's
difficult to do because you have little
space nowadays this pawn structure is
much better known than back then so
nowadays a good a good master level
player probably would avoid this like
the plague but back then it could easily
happen even in a inter zonal tournament
which was one of the qualification state
stages for the World Championship back
then but let's see how Petrosian
continues b5 was played by black tried
to get some play on the Queen side this
is a slightly debatable decision because
it also weakens the Queen side even
further however it's difficult to give
black a very constructive advice as this
structure is really very very
unfavorable a foreigner was played very
very important white gets some play on
the Queen side going as soon as possible
he has a totally stable center so he
plays on the flanks black went before
yeah there's only a choice between
various evils you can also take but
after that the a6 pond would be a very
very substantial weakness so before and
yeah here we come to one of the first
interesting situations where does the
knight go to a 2 or 2 b1
Petrosian goes to b 1 this is a better
Square compared to a 2 if you go to a 2
like place that's an a5 it's not so
clear where the knight is heading it
might go here or here to b3 or d3 but
from there the best thing I can do is
maybe take a piece that appears on c5
the night comes up there but the knight
is not attacking anything from b1 and
now d2 the night is aimed at the juicy
c4 square where it looks at 85 and d6
so the night really has a great post on
c4 this is one reason why b5 is a
debatable decision because after this a4
sequence white really gets those
additional points of entry on the
queenside shree Varner went with 95
maybe he was thinking that all this is
not very very problematic for him
because he can play 95 which yeah in a
way it closes the C file however
Petrosian now played a very very strong
move the move that always needs to be
considered carefully White has got
almost all ports on light squares and
discarded dark squared bishop this dark
squared bishop is normally very very
powerful and important to God the dark
squares that are just weakened by the
fact that all pawns on light squares
however here white has a very strong
move in capturing the night why is this
especially strong the reason is that
after D takes the pawn structure is
changed for white in a favorable way
because the c5 pawn now is something
that white can attack white also it has
the excellent c4 outpost for insight
from C for the night attacks to pawns
white also has gotten a protected passed
pawn which at the moment is not super
relevant but it is important in the long
run
definitely so white has gained by by
taking them but he has given up the
bishop so other dark squares a problem
in fact in this specific situation they
are not because black has no way to
enter White's positions and use those
dark squares yeah this is a totally
different animal with the bishop on g7
then let's say the bishop being on on b6
and black playing c4
if you just imagine the bishop would
come to b6 from black and he would be
able to play C for this
would have huge activity in whites camp
but it is on g7 and cannot really do
much she also can't enter with the Queen
and now the next strong move Petrosian
now plays Bishop b5 this is just the
strongest movement of position Y to b5
the big point is white wants to play a
set up like this night c4 92 night to g3
those are the ideal spots for the
Knights the Knights attack pots and then
look at the important square here on f5
the bishop is well well placed on
beehive because it does two things it
possibly allows trade of the ships
trading the LightSquared Bishop of
course would be fantastic for what if we
look at the move Bishop d7 for example
what gladly will take him like this and
then play this Knight to c4 and the
other Knight to f5 with the LightSquared
Bishop being exchanged this f5 weakness
is even worse as there's no piece that
can capture them theoretically speaking
a knight could guard their five square
but this is difficult to achieve after
96 rooks e1 yeah black is in dire
straits the night will come to f5 and
then white words slowly but surely build
up the pressure to win the c5 pawn black
player went there should be seven and
now 92 we complete our development and
want to go here with the bishop won't be
seven which this look this this is
Bishop does not look very nice he and
looking at this year but he needed to
move it somewhere and Bishop d7 was very
undesirable as we have seen yeah 92 and
now black went 98 here we come to the
next great decision by white
and the the second reason why this is a
classic of of positional play Petrosian
now decided to capture on the eighth
it's a funny capture you rarely see a
good-looking bishop taking a knight on
the back rank but it is simply the best
decision that white can make him why the
position is very very closed at the
moment there is no open file so the
Knights gain in strength black's knight
was just about to jump to d6 where he
might be this might be able to trade a
knight coming to c4 or even under
favorable certain circumstances take on
b5
now the night carrying to d6 is an
improvement from luck and with the
capture we come to a typical situation
where we can argue that what is
important is what's left on the board
and not what has been traded the pieces
that are left if we look at this
position now all this looks looks very
very normal
the pieces that are left are two knights
against two bishops and we see that the
f8 bishop is so terrible it's looking at
its own pawn it has no way to be
activated while the white knights are
ready to jump here and they put huge
pressure on blacks position the c5 pawn
is just a terrible weakness Bishop c8
yeah ready to capture the knight coming
to f5 white absolutely never wants to
put the knife there when it can be
captured or maybe never is a bit much
there always some concrete
considerations but it rarely is a good
idea
for example if white play this now like
an maybe ok this is not working
to be honest I was thinking about moves
like that where black might be able to
enter with with the Queen but it's not
working here for conclude reasons yeah I
mean I should should show the reasons
I'm sorry about that
here there
also one can take and still there is
nothing going on
plus there's possibly rook g1 which also
refutes this idea in any case you want a
piece on a5 another pawn yeah how did
Petrosian continue with patience you
have all the time in the world he
cancelled why not the energy want to
rooks
involved in this battle against the c5
pawn rook e8 King g2 and now why this
burning up yeah an ideal setup the c5
pawn is the target black now when the
Queen a6 yeah this does not look very
good as it gives up the e5 pawn but yeah
what exactly should black play very very
difficult to imagine how black could
could defend him one possible way to
continue could be Bishop d7 just marking
time yeah it how it is right continue
one idea is Knight e3
intending to put a knight on f5 when
there's a capture possible this is one
one idea or might contrive to reposition
the g3 night all the way to d3 this is
also a possible way to improve the
position black really has no counter
play the only thing that you need to
watch out for piece sacrifices yep or f5
at some very very favorable moment
moment very hard to imagine that's
happening yeah if we consider this idea
maybe Knight h1 is an idea let's say
black marks time but here we are now the
idea would be to play Knight e3 and then
take on c5 yeah white can maneuver
behind the pawn chains and he really has
time to find his optimal setup in the
game Schriever played Queen to a6 yeah
and now it's an interesting situation
and this was giving up the e5 pawn and I
think what black tried to do is he
wanted to sort of bait whites to take
the pawn and then get a little bit of
activity um in fact here Petrosian did
not need to take the pawn on e5 he he
did so but he didn't need to do it he
also had all those strengthening ideas
that I am sure before after Bishop d7
for example this maneuver is still
possible however the capture is no big
deal now you always should be there
should be very young yeah very cautious
with cashing in from very favorable
positions sometimes people give up the
whole strategic advantage for just one
pawn and here we really need to check if
we want to take this pawn and activate
blacks Bishop for example if we look at
this I played rook c7 first but this is
what I was talking about black now get
this Bishop on the diagonal and gets a
little bit more breathing space for this
piece
what white needed to do he needed to to
check beforehand if this is a problem or
not in fact it turns out that this
bishop is basically pointing into thin
air there is nothing that it detects and
especially the White King position is
very very secure as everything is is
shielded by this big big pawn chain yeah
after some preparation he v was possible
to play
yeah if black node takes only five which
he did
White has a favorable transformation
yeah but what else is there white is
threatening not f5 or pushing the pawns
further black took only five ninety five
hundred rupee five twin takes and rook
c5
this way of simplification was clearly
am envisioned by the chosen beforehand
and now White has a pretty easy winning
endgame the point is that a five hangs
and is not possible to defend white
still has the deep horn and he's got
those ideas of activating the knight the
bishop c8 he just grabbed him and traded
down to winning rook endgame yeah
two rocks actually the point is that the
D pawn is just far far too quick g7 and
here the black the black player resigned
yeah there are many ways now to win the
game the simplest is after that's a king
e7 to just promote and wide wins the
King opponent game by infiltrating he
still has this this B pawn and as the
winner or alternatively black could have
played a route to aid and then we set
this in motion yeah now white can
strengthen his position at will King
here kingi form and so on a very nice
strategic display by Petrosian yeah what
to remember from this game that's the
key point of those games that that we
look at you want to learn tall
structures and motifs this pawn
structure that was created here is
really in almost all cases hugely
favorable for what
the only exception could be where black
is very much ready to get this bishop
activated just I mean it's very
unrealistic and to get this but let's
say this bishop would be on c7 then it's
a different matter with black activating
this piece along here but with the
bishop and tooled on b7 on g7 this is a
fantastic position for white he has the
use space advantage the f5 Square
and based on this big clamp on the
position he can play on the queenside
this was really a model game for this
structure things to remember night to be
won a more much more purposeful retreat
than to a two because you get to the
good square and see for the capture here
initiated in favorable pawn structure
transformation after which the C pawn
becomes very weak in this capture very
strong to make sure that the knight is
not reaching the strong locating square
on d6 after that white made sure that
the whole structure stayed closed so the
black bishops never got any activity and
long-term those pawns proved to be too
fatally weak to to maintain this kind of
fall structure really pops up time and
time and again in those openings if
black does really does not really know
what he's doing so this these lines like
the other one can really be recommended
for white players if you want an
interesting weapon against the Kings
Indian against less experienced
opposition you're very often we get
those kind of one-sided one-sided games
1 if black knows what is doing ok it
might be equal but it's still
interesting to play alright I hope you
enjoyed this instructive game that maybe
introduced the new kind of pawn
structure to you that you now will be
able to maybe play for as white or white
is black thanks for watching